hi this is kim from khan academy and
today i'm learning more about article 7
of the us constitution which is the
provision that specified the conditions
for the constitution to become law it
reads the ratification of the
conventions of nine states shall be
sufficient for the establishment of this
constitution between the states so
ratifying the same although this sounds
simple it reminds us that when the
framers finished drafting the
constitution in philadelphia in 1787 it
was by no means a done deal at least
nine states had to ratify the
constitution in order to replace the
existing government under the articles
of confederation to learn more about the
ratification process i sought out the
help of two experts mark graber is the
jacob a france professor of
constitutionalism at the university of
maryland francis king kerry school of
law michael rappaport is the darling
foundation professor at the university
of san diego school of law professor
graber can you tell us a little bit
about the political context of
ratification what was going on at this
time as
the framers tried to put a new
constitution into the fabric of the
united states
well one central problem of the articles
of confederation was the articles
require that all 13 states consent for
any amendment
and it turned out at this time rhode
island was a great outlier so rhode
island wasn't going to consent to much
of anything
and in fact rhode island did not even
send delegates to the convention that
drafted the constitution so the framers
knew
that if you had the unanimous rule
for ratification it would not work so
instead they chose nine it's about
two-thirds three-fourths
in part to make sure rhode island and
one outlier
could not prevent adoption
so
let's remember there's two stages here
in how the constitution gets written and
ratified so first it's written in what's
called the drafting convention or the
philadelphia convention which was held
during the summer of 1787
and in that convention there was pretty
much an agreement that the federal
government needed to be made stronger
but that was just a proposal in order
for the constitution to be ratified it
needed nine of the 13 states and um so
it went to the second stage
and there things were in some ways going
to be more difficult because there was a
variety of viewpoints in the different
states and the main question that came
up in state after state after state was
was the federal government being given
too much additional power
under the previous regime of the
articles of confederation the federal
government had very limited powers
and the constitution was going to give
the federal government more power they
wanted a strategy that
once the ball started rolling
states that were slower were going to be
faced with a choice
you could get in on the inside
and maybe effect some changes early
but if you were left out
whatever happened would happen without
you in a lot of states at the end were
fearful of being left out
this strategy worked and as they went
through in tough states as time went on
so new hampshire
virginia
new york north carolina rhode island in
order to get ratification each time they
promised will will have a bill of rights
and those states added a a list of
amendments that they wanted added to the
constitution so was it controversial
that the framers decided that only nine
states would be necessary to ratify the
constitution
very controversial one of the central
points of anti-federalist
was that this was illegal
that the existing constitution said all
states and therefore only all states
could change the constitution
so in in that respect it was somewhat
controversial another way in which it
departed from the article so the article
said you needed the state legislatures
to approve the amendments and the u.s
constitution said no we want state
conventions
special bodies elected by the people to
approve these things why did they say
that because they feared that the state
legislatures who would be losing a lot
of power under the constitution would
vote against it so they wanted sort of
to go directly to the people in these
conventions and bypass the state
legislatures so we know that there were
some opponents of this new constitution
how close did they actually come to
preventing its ratification
well it was a very
close fight
we look back on it and eventually all 13
states are going to ratify and it just
looks like oh well that wasn't too much
of a trouble but it was very close and
things could have easily gone in the
opposite direction um one of the ways in
which it was close was that they were
just very close votes
massachusetts was
187 to 168. new hampshire was 57-47
new york was 30-27 so very close votes
involved you know a couple of people
changing their mind and
that would have meant various states
didn't ratify in addition to that um
some of the states actually did not
ratify
so the first thing that happened was
rhode island early on in the process
says
we don't like your your horrible
constitution they all expected that
we're not going to hold even a
convention you want us to hold the
convention we're not going to hold a
convention we're just going to have a
vote in the state
and that vote in the state 90 of the
people voted against the constitution so
in a way rhode island actually
voted against stratification although
they didn't use the proper method
north carolina also they held a
convention and they were very upset
about there not being a bill of rights
in the constitution
and they just didn't approve it they
didn't disapprove it they just did
nothing and they they waited so
in a way two of the states
voted against ratification north
carolina had not yet ratified when
george washington took office so in fact
when george washington took office there
were only 11 states in the union at the
end of the day
crucial people i think decided it was
better to sign the constitution
and be in on the ground floor
then stay out and see what happened
interesting so who are some of the major
players involved here and what were they
arguing about
there were the federalists who were
arguing in favor of ratifying the
constitution and the anti-federalists
who were arguing against ratifying the
constitution so the federalists the two
of the very famous ones um are familiar
names alexander hamilton and james
madison
those two people though were also
particularly important because they
decided hamilton said we're going to
have a tough time getting ratification
in new york we need to write some essays
defending the constitution and so
hamilton and madison cooperated together
and wrote what we now call the
federalist papers which were simply
essays written in the newspapers
trying to urge the new york convention
to ratify the constitution eventually
those essays were sent to other states
and became known and now we we come to
revere those those essays as the
federalist papers but they were
originally just kind of um advocacy
pieces for ratifying the convention now
there were also anti-federalists the
anti-federalists in part was simply
people who oppose the constitution and
just as it's the case that say people
opposed obamacare from both the left and
the right
uh people who oppose the constitution
opposed it for many different reasons
and one of their problems was they were
not a united bunch
but in general these were people fearful
of a very strong national government
they believed states were sovereign they
wanted to keep power local and they were
very fearful of what they perceived to
be an elite who would run the
constitution after ratification
the names that people may know who were
anti-federalists were people like
patrick henry and samuel adams
so what were some of the major arguments
made in favor of adopting this new
constitution there were i think two
types of arguments
people felt that the articles were not
working properly they had all kinds of
problems and one of the strongest
arguments that the federalist papers
made was that if we don't fix this and
make for a stronger union together what
will happen is we'll break apart look at
what happens when you have a bunch of
states
all next to one another in a in a land
area we we know what that looks like
it's called europe and what happens in
europe they fight wars with one another
all the time and those wars are very
problematic you have to have big armies
standing armies now there were also the
particular arguments about what powers
were missing
that the federal government had that the
main arguments were made was the federal
government did not have enough power so
they didn't have for example the taxing
power and they didn't have a way of
enforcing treaties against the states
very well
and some of the states were putting
tariffs up so interfering with trade
within the country so states would set
tariffs on out-of-state goods
states wouldn't contribute to the
national government second we needed to
present a united front to foreign
governments
so we were very worried what would
happen if south carolina formed an
alliance with england
and north carolina formed an alliance
with france that would be good the
country needed to speak with one voice
so those are some of the arguments made
for adopting the constitution what were
some of the arguments against adopting
this new constitution
well first argument was even though most
anti-federalists admitted the articles
needed some repair they said it's not
really urgent it's not like the house is
going to fall down tomorrow it's just
you know the wind is coming through
and we can figure it out
we really want a better constitution
the other arguments were the
constitution put too much power in the
national government
it put too much power in elites the fear
was if you had national elections only
elites would win
if you had local elections people the
people actually knew would win
so they thought a big national
government would be too far away from
the people to know what they really
needed as opposed to state governments
which they perceived as being sort of
more personal closer to the needs of
individuals so
compare two kinds of elections first
how many people really know anyone
who runs the senator
who runs for president that you're on a
first name basis with
now compare you're in a school club
chances are when someone runs for an
officer of the school club you know who
they are
another type of argument was
if you give the federal government this
power and even if and the federalists
always argue that the power was limited
that they were being given to the
federal government
and the anti-federalist came back and
said well you say it's limited but what
we know from historical experience is
that once a government's in power
it tends to seize more power there's a
lot of vague phrases in the constitution
and the federal government will use
those vague phrases to assert greater
and greater power what were some of the
strategies that the framers used to
entice some of the opponents of a strong
central government to ratify the
constitution so the first thing that
they did was to try to build up momentum
so they knew there were certain states
which were strongly in favor of
ratification small states sometimes
wanted ratification so the first state
that comes in is delaware and they vote
30 to 0 for the constitution
and a bunch of early states so
let's say the first
five states
all vote for ratification by pretty
lopsided margins so that builds up a
kind of momentum all right we have five
states we only need four more of course
the the next ones that were going to
come we're going to be much more
difficult
and
they then needed to change
their strategy at that point you know
they argued like crazy the federalist
papers are a very famous example
they indicated they'd be open to
amendment once the constitution was
ratified
then again in pennsylvania
when anti-federalists boycotted the
convention and the result is the
convention didn't have a quorum they
ordered the sergeant-at-arms to a tavern
the sergeant-at-arms found some
boycotting anti-federalists and
physically put them in the building so
they could count for a quorum
that's terrific that one doesn't get
told in a whole lot of history books
wow the first the framers could play
rough and tumble politics with the best
of them a lot of the things that pop up
at the time of the framing i think we
look back on today and imagine how would
this work in today's era with you know
330 million americans do you think the
system under the articles of
confederation with a smaller more local
government could possibly work today
well among other things the articles had
no great means of collecting taxes or
gaining revenue given that modern
government needs trillions of dollars
the articles if you got a thousand
dollars it was a miracle so the articles
clearly don't work but the the articles
were inadequate for 18th century
government they were clearly inadequate
or would be clearly inadequate for 21st
century government now the constitution
appears to have been adequate for 18th
century government whether it is
adequate for 21st century government is
a fair question
one of the interesting questions about
the the constitution is how democratic
is the constitution this debate about
how democratic the constitution is
actually enters into the question about
ratification on one level
the constitution
was democratic because each state in
these ratification conventions
voted on whether to ratify
by majority vote
on the other hand at the federal level
the ratification requirement required
9 out of 13. and the idea there would be
we needed more buy-in we needed a
limitation on simple majority rule in
order to to make the system function
well in order to produce a a
constitution that would have support
from from the whole country the
interesting thing about that super
majority rule and something that people
don't often make the connection with is
we probably owe our bill of rights
to that super majority rule
because if only seven of the 13 states
that the mere majority
had been needed to to ratify the
constitution
then it's quite possible that the
federalists wouldn't have had to
promise to put a bill of rights into the
constitution because they wouldn't have
needed to and they were
initially quite opposed to putting a
bill of rights in the constitution
it was only the fact that they needed
nine out of the 13 states that that
really forced their hand and forced them
to promise that they would put the bill
of rights in there so we see the in
terms of the ratification that there's
both sort of democratic elements but
also uh republican or super majority
elements
so we've learned that it wasn't easy to
ratify the constitution the framers
bypassed state legislatures and went
directly to the people in state
conventions hoping that momentum and
arguments for a stronger federal
government would entice the opponents of
the constitution to ratify it it took
until
1789 for 9 out of 13 states to ratify
the constitution and finally make it law
to learn more about article 7 check out
the national constitution center's
interactive constitution and khan
academy's resources on u.s government
and politics